are adults over Halloween costumes
nearly two-thirds of Americans say they
aren't dressing up according to a new
Yahoo yugov poll experts explain why the
article says Halloween is around the
corner but data from the latest Yahoo
yugu poll suggest that most us adults
won't be Dawning costumes for the
celebration this year according to the
poll while 22% are opting to dress up
for the spooky holiday 63% have chosen
to skip out this season while 14%
haven't decided one way or another many
of us might find all the hoopla
surrounding Halloween a bit debilitating
the article is painting the lack of
adult participation in a child's holiday
as some kind of sad thing they're seeing
it as some sort of bad sign about our
culture this is actually one of the only
good signs that we've seen in a long
time this this is one of the only
positive social developments that we
have seen in our culture in decades